montréal est une plaque tournante pour
l'industrie du sit in se conclure et
c'est à montréal capitale du cirque que
s'est tenue pendant quatre jours une
grande rencontre entre 250
professionnels venus de 25 pays
prendre le temps d'expliquer toute la
machine
comment ça peut voyager quelle forme
peut s'adapter ou non donc ces faits
moment-là qu'ils font finalement qu'on
travaille tout le temps une journée de
speed dating permettait aux artistes de
présenter leur projet aux diffuseurs du
monde entier en cinq minutes top chrono
et comme un sens by southwest du cirque
on a ça pour le cinéma austin on a ça
pour la musique ça je les fais souvent
et c'est un petit peu cette énergie là
c'est à dire qu'on a un melting-pot de
gens qui viennent de partout dans le
monde pour diffuser chercher l'essence
d'un spectacle d'une heure et quart à de
le résumer en cinq minutes 15 catégories
car ces gens 3 en discussions avancées
un annoncé des mois et des mois de
création c'est des cahiers de notes et
d'un coup il faut trouver cinq minutes
la danse
koussa gens magnifiques à montréal est
devenue une destination circassienne
depuis le succès du cirque du soleil
d'ailleurs son co fondateur guy
laliberté possède une fortune estimée
par le magazine forbes à un milliard
cent millions de dollars depuis la ville
compte plusieurs compagnies qui ont fait
leur marque comme le cirque éloize et
les 7 doigts de la main
sans compter la création de l'école
nationale de cirque qui attire des
artistes de partout sur la planète
parce que justement par le fait qu un
peu plus explosé en nombre de compagnies
en nombre d'artistes sur le marché le
marché est un peu plus contingenté donc
mais il ya la place pour tout le monde
le poteau monde il faut faire ce métier
avant tout par passion
une industrie qui génère des retombées
importantes pour la métropole québécoise
on peut évaluer facilement le nombre
autour de 3500 4000 travailleurs
le cirque la culture en général c'est un
moteur économique identitaire et sociale
majeure et montréal sur une erre d'aller
la grande rencontre de l'industrie
organisés par montréal complètement
cirque a connu en dix ans une croissance
exponentielle
au début on avait tout simplement comme
une petite vanne
après ça on a passé un autobus qui est à
21 passagers
il a cette année on de deux autobus si
je me fie au numéro que j'ai vu
aujourd'hui en croire les participants
au mi6 et l'industrie canadienne du
cirque a pas fini de nous surprendre et
de nous éblouir et syna by alexandre
chartier radio canada montréal